yeah welcome to this video a 15 minute
game on ICC has just started and my
opponent played one before all right so
let's go f5 yeah you don't get this
opening too often tend to forget what
what's good but let's see huh
93 this is some an uncommon move usually
what green just plays Knight f3 yard
drop some the bishop back so what's the
idea and maybe you know it's a strange
move if you ask me you have a castle
maybe you will take and play 95 hmm ok
yeah this is very possible but I'm sure
that that brings some many benefits I
can also just play Bishop e7 with a good
position which is often a good idea just
retreat the bishop oh come on I will
treat this the the weird thing about
this position is that this Bishop on e5
has no natural retreat Square and then
you can go to g3 if I attack it with
knight c6 probably but g3 is a bit weird
for for position where you move before
and has have to be 2 squares your
natural kind of position for the bishop
so on this all makes a rather strange of
pressure to the
on me all right let's see what what is
going to play his son rather high rated
to 173 is pretty high in the 15-minute
pool with my 2200 son among the active
players I'm around I'm not sure maybe
rank 20 or something
Knight to b5 the emphasis will be a
weird game I don't understand the rules
yeah okay
can I could I could go all night a six
simply applied e6 yeah I think d6 I want
the knight on c6 later not quite sure
from a6 what what good a dad would do so
what now just cancels on do I have
something better a question is um how do
I set up my center pawns see 625 or
maybe c5 96 then there are many many
ideas
mmm now see five maybe first then 96 see
five you could go see four yeah it's not
so clear let's castle first I mean what
white is playing is complete nonsense
I'll be honest about this black is
already very good but of course I mean
that still needs to be refuted he's
simply losing time with moving pieces
twice and so on so how do I open up the
position now as quickly as possible
I could go d5 yeah maybe g5 takes 95 now
what c5 first I'd like to put this pawn
in the center controlling deform it's
not a developing move that's a bad thing
you
and I'm suddenly okay I can always call
96 95 this is clear but probably it
cannot refute it outright maybe g5 was
better it's hard to tell
yeah I'm expecting III now on all night
F threesome one of those moves probably
not have three and I'll probably play
Knight to c6 and t5 in any case one idea
could be if he if he would play Knight
f3 could be a six and B five the sister
may be an interesting possibility a six
b5 and gambit stop trying to win even
more Tam beam suddenly playable but I
expect you three anyway any other mousse
that Knight f3 or III release would be
weird
he needs to speed up his son development
on the kingside hasn't moved anything
don't think white can afford them other
moves on g3 RF g 5c txt 425 is one idea
not sure that it's so good but it's a
decent option okay move this Knight
again
so g5 now Ian would be would be normal
we should be six winning a tempo and
then define here this is better so that
I can take with the bishop at the end
I'm okay I also want to play a bit
quicker than water fall behind on the
clock much ah this is the idea I mean
it's really ugly but it prevents g5 okay
yeah let's develop pieces yeah it
weakens deform but has the sole benefit
of keeping the position close for a
while now
Knight f3 he Theatre perfect reform
problem
so how do I open this up one ideas 97
intending Bishop f6 or maybe f5 and
that's one idea
right if I have you can go d3 and it's
not not obvious what I should do next
smooth
mmm okay what will be his legs move
probably not f3 then I have the special
chief forms tending to exchange and then
play on the dark squares so I could play
um a strengthening move like rook e8 or
something just wait a move totally plays
Knight f3
if he doesn't can play 97 anyway but
maybe 97 SM is good any arm ok let's
let's speed up intending Bishop to have
6 them all right so Bishop g4 now the
idea being to get control over the dark
squares especially deform so take on f3
Bishop f6 the idea then I have good
control okay
yeah this certainly possible King let's
grab this first I want to exchange the
night how do I get this exchange and not
a problem and most ideally not against
the bishop
okay this bishop isn't so strong but it
would would be on f6 if I exchanged
knights and get the bishop to have six
I'm I'm very very good in this position
so I'm thinking about really moving this
piece yeah come to g5 and then Knight f6
or Knight b6 something like that I would
what about 95 first let's check this
first I can I can just play Bishop e2
mmm yeah Bishop g5 flop some like a
pretty unnatural moves ready hmm how do
i strengthen this disposition I'm to
improve yeah Knight f6 can probably even
take only 7 and I'm not sure I want to
play against with two knights against
two bishops this isn't it's really a
Sodom a good idea maybe it would be
would be M would be possible you have it
and sure
yeah might be six is also an idea it
looks unnatural but um I'm not quite
sure what to play otherwise and let's
say the other moves are I don't like to
tweet much as well
yeah probably I shouldn't have given him
the the possibility to to play this on
strange movie form it helped him really
surprisingly had helped him okay
97 I want to get rid of this night
yeah the same idea was possible Knight
b6 or Knight f6 I don't didn't want to
spend too much time on this it's not
clear what's what's better I'm already
pretty far behind of the clock mostly
asking myself what I what I was what I
did wrong because obviously I'm I didn't
manage to really refute this nonsense
and this is a bit disappointing okay
Bishop to g4 okay scrap him if he
recaptures I played Bishop f6 trying to
exchange this bishop oh okay I see you
you should be - we'll go would be one
that if I remove it you can take p7
uh-huh okay anyway I need to take here
first no alternative so but this is
interesting now unfortunately I don't
have much time because Bishop to d4 is
really interesting would be 7 okay he
can play route b7 but I would have a
very strong Bishop on d4
I can always take d7 and he takes on b2
and that's not much going on okay Bishop
to g4 would be 7 whoo yeah but it's not
obvious how I improve after this this is
a problem it looks nice but it's not
them so so clear what I should should do
afterwards ok let's go f5 attack his
pawn chain if he would take allow me to
take without him being able to recapture
the pawn
I am I would have have would have d5 as
that's a good point of attack a good
weakness that I can play against and if
he placed III he needs to yeah be
comfortable with the idea that I take he
takes and then b5 I would have
dangerous-looking pawns on the Queen
side of course he then I can play FY you
find stuff like that
it's a very sharp then also on d3 okay
he captures this is some surprise okay
okay I mean it cannot be bad right with
the pawn on d5
yeah so route d5 on big place Queen b3
prolly mean okay but I have amongst
others the move C form cannot believe
that this should be bad
yeah
yeah okay I need to pay off this Heavy D
fibers just hanging
so b5 he can actually take so all this
is based on on on tricks M that the Sun
still has some somehow holding but okay
tricks are tricks what can you do I have
no possibility to cover it raining
yeah the book is of course in a somewhat
shaky position hmm Jim what should I do
probably just take it I'm yeah far
behind on the clock
unfortunately b5 now wouldn't threaten
anything at some it's a bit
uncomfortable timewise also especially
timewise don't hear the position too
much okay I want to bring the rope to
have seven caverns seventh rank and get
it out of this strange position on d5
unfortunately this is still yeah this is
15 minutes with no increment so at the
end time it will be probably a time a
time thing
I absolutely have no idea why Isis he
doesn't offer this is increment like
1010 or something it's simply the much
better time control okay I'm so drop
back to to cover c7 ya know wants to
play rock c7 can cover this with the
little trick if you would play rock c7
now I can capture twice because of made
only one yeah i fou q1 also
so rookie one check now queenie one
would take see am this what relief of
some some other pressure yeah this is
some should be equal now really you can
of course play on time okay this is
really is a straight draw no and which
i'm a major mistake simply because of
the time yeah this perpetually I must do
it I have no time the wrong are wrong so
yeah a draw after all which is a bit of
a disappointment after after the first
couple of moves but I really didn't
didn't play well I mean okay obviously
if you this must be refuted in a way
complete complete weird so yeah not
quite sure let's say d6 cannot be so bad
I mean 26 I can't use the phone button
want to do a quick recap here
so this d6
castles see for now yeah yeah there's
more than one interesting and
alternative of course I'm not sure about
this move it cannot be bad really but
okay 93 and now after 96 he played this
weird deformed move cool I know actually
I played this and then he play d4 yeah
maybe I must go default immediately it's
not it's not bad obviously yeah this is
some standard position where I think I
have extra tempo because of this weird
night b5 move and it's probably am yeah
a very comfortable equality something
something like this no yeah this is
really a strange move but it's probably
okay preventing d5 yeah here I could
have played 94 so not too bad okay
yeah it's probably around equal don't
think that dumb and his side should have
something something ready yeah here I
was pretty optimistic and also this move
looks weird to me but probably is just
in time to to fix this structural
problems probably him I need to play
differently app let's see form yeah
he is very quickly run on this pawns but
now I have no way to cover C form so
probably c4 was bad already
maybe something something like this to
have this idea but then he has got got
this one I don't know maybe it's a
problem maybe it's around equal anyway
I tend to be too optimistic if the
opponent has played weird opening yeah
alright I hope you enjoyed it anyway it
wasn't the most exciting game ever yeah
thanks for watching talk to you soon
with new stuff